c'est un homme d'affaires de 69 ans qui
a commencé sa carrière grâce à
l'entreprise de son père fredrik trump
qui déjà à l'époque était investi dans
l'immobilier et dans la gestion
d'appartements locatifs dans certains
quartiers de new york
après donald trump lui s'est investi
davantage en immobilier à multiplier les
projets il suffit par exemple de penser
à la fameuse trump towers à new york ou
encore assez casino atlantic city et à
las vegas ou plus près de nous
évidemment à toronto et vancouver avec
ses tours appartements et partout où il
passe il m'est toujours son nom sur
chacun des immeubles mais donald trump
c'est aussi un producteur et un
animateur de télévision rappelez-vous de
l'émission de télé-réalité dia prentice
pour certains épisodes ils pouvaient
aller engranger jusqu'à 15 millions de
dollars juste pour lui-même il y avait
également l'émission miss univers qui
l'a complétait jusqu'à cette année sa
fortune selon le magazine forbes serait
estimé à 4 milliards de dollars et il a
récemment dévoilé ses revenus pour
l'année 2014 il aurait en fait amassé
362 millions de dollars provenant de 168
sources différentes
mais donald trump ce n'est pas toujours
un palmarès très reluisant en fait ces
entreprises ont fait 4 faillite
en 18 ans la première la plus
retentissante c'était le casino le trump
taj mahal en 1991 où il s'était endetté
de 3 milliards de dollars ensuite il y a
eu le trump plaza hôtel un endettement
de 7 550 millions de dollars
il a dû revendre sa compagnie aérienne
et ses bateaux pour se remettre à flot
sans oublier deux autres entreprises
dans lesquelles il s'est endetté pour
plus de 2 milliards de dollars
en fait il s'est toujours protégé sous
la fameuse loi 11 qui permet de
restructurer l'entreprise sans devoir la
fermer et même si son nom est sur toutes
les compagnies donald trump n'a jamais
fait de faillite personnelle
il reste que sa personnalité plaît à
beaucoup d'américains après tout il a
échoué plusieurs fois mais il s'est
relevé et a rebondi
c'est aussi ça le rêve américain